hi I'm Erik Bosse and stranger things
season 3 followed up its first two
seasons with that classic def or
brothers mix of warm feels and cold dark
interdimensional foreboding that makes
this Netflix series the thrilling
nostalgia porn that we stay up all night
to binge watch was that sentence a run
on you'll get more punctuation when my
sleep cycle does spoiler warning before
we continue because I'm about to talk
about these stranger things season 3
final final scene a post-credits scene I
don't want to ruin it for you so if you
haven't seen all eight of the new
episodes of season three pause here then
come back so you know we could chat okay
are we clear so the eighth and final
episode of stranger things season 3 ends
pretty tragically our heroes defeat the
mine player but at a cost with joy
spires turning the keys to the Machine
sealing the gates with a blast that
fries a bunch of scientists within a
radius but also our hero hopper choice
just had no patience had to turn the
keys both herself could not wait the
what six seconds for hopper to run
around and help her go whatever in the
episodes epilogue Joyce will and Elle
all move away as all the kids help them
pack up and Elle reads hoppers written
out speech that he never had the
patience to give her in person all while
Peter Gabriel's cover of David Bowie's
heroes plays and we cry we suck up our
tears because there's a post-credits
scene posthumous love you 3,000 notes
from the hero and post-credit scenes
what are we watching here okay the
post-credits scene returns to the
Russian base and come check someplace in
Siberian frozen lands that I am horribly
mr. Madsen we see some guards walking
down a cellblock then 1 instructs the
other whoa not the American we're
retrieving a different Russian prisoner
dragging him down a stairwell and
leading him to a cage where hey that's a
familiar face well not really a face a
dim accor Ken now back in season 1 L
presumably killed the Dimmick organ but
just as her disappearance was revealed
to be a mere transference to the
upside-down
we have speculated a demagogue and could
also be alive somewhere out in the
cosmos just waiting to ruin our
Christmas lights now instead of the
Democrat itself season 2 introduces us
to the spin-off demo dogs but in episode
6 of this season 3 we got a little clue
that old toothpaste might return when
Erica noticed a tall cage in the depths
of the underground Russian base how big
did you say that demo Google was big 19
or so why and it looks as though now
that the Dimmick organ has returned
through one of the other gateways in
Russia that that scientists alexey
referred to and now the russians are
using it as a kind of punishment of
political prisoners or maybe using
prisoners to feed this scientific
discovery and continue researching it
for maybe bio-weapon purposes or maybe
all of these things but it is not just
the return of endemic organ that this
scene sets up it's the return of another
seemingly fallen figure that mysterious
American in the first cell who could
this be
I'm sorry barb heads this is almost
certainly hopper actor David Harbor
alluded to his future fate in the
interview by pointing to this scene and
el actor Millie Bobby said that she
played her final scene with quote pure
devastation and sadness as a distraught
child that just lost her father or so
she thinks
now there are actually a few other big
clues that you might have missed that
hopper is the American in that cell for
starters the Russian Terminator II agent
who hunts them down throughout the
season consistently refers to hopper as
quote the American the American is
essentially all Russian characters name
for hopper in these episodes it's also
worth noting that the explosion scene
showed all these scientists bodies
disintegrating but deliberately did not
show hoppers body so it's not too
implausible for hopper to have been
sucked into that gate and trapped in the
upside down only to be discovered by one
of the Russians through one of their
gateways but the clue I really liked was
in the music of the final scene Peter
Gabriel's cover of Bowie's heroes is a
specific choice has lovely
instrumentation that gives it all a
sorrowful quality like the words of a
loved one who died tragically and it was
actually showed up in stranger things
before remember in season 1 the episode
in which will buyers body was discovered
in the water this was the music that
played over everyone mourning someone
that they thought had died but that
person was actually trapped in the
upside-down
it's basically stranger things fake
death theme and finally there could be a
clue in hoppers speech to elder in the
scene his final words to her
keep the door open three inches yeah
this is a callback to hoppers no closed
door rule for ELLs bedroom smooches with
my can rule with which every father of a
teenage daughter can probably relate but
this could also carry an additional
metaphorical meaning for L to remember
that her father hasn't really left her
he's just right on the other side of a
door and that she could see him again if
she could just keep it open three inches
and by the way I just gotta say I love
you three inches
bit of a missed opportunity there now we
do have more coming up for stranger
things season three including a big
breakdown of all the cool Easter eggs
whoo 80s pop culture especially the
really really sneaky ones that you might
have overlooked so keep it now for that
but comment down below with your
thoughts on stranger things season 3 and
follow me on instagram and twitter at da
vas and subscribe to new rockstars to
break down some theories of everything
you love thanks for joining me bye
[Music]